"We do such good work in so many ways and this is one of the more public ways
we get to demonstrate how we support Mercy Care
and the outreach of Saint Joseph's
Hospital.
"Mercy care depends on grants,  on contributions, on all kinds of financial support from the public.
We do very comprehensive health care service. We have integrated behavioral health,
we have primary care, pediatrics, HIV care. recuperative care for persons who are homeless
and are being released from local hospitals, have no place but the street to go."
"I'm here to support the race because they've done such a wonderful job in supporting me."
"We're a Mercy hospital. That means that anybody walks through our doors, we're gonna take care of and
mission is to take care of those patients and their families. And nothing makes us more happy,
nothing makes us more fulfilled, than to
complete and accomplish that mission."